[Musica]
il contributo delle donne ha
l'intelligenza artificiale vedo
tantissime donne tantissime ragazze
giovani e spero davvero che oggi
condividiamo un idea ci possiamo fidare
dell'intelligenza artificiale ci
sentiamo parlare tanto ma ci possiamo
fidare non ha un'arma troppo potente che
prima o poi può avere delle conseguenze
negative
noi tutti i giorni usiamo sistemi
algoritmi che si appoggiano già al
programmi di sì di intelligenza
artificiale
usiamo questi software per cercare
notizie informazioni sulla nostra salute
sulla salute dei nostri cari sulla
politica sull'economia ci fidiamo
quando noi facciamo delle ricerche con
google ci fidiamo e ci appoggiamo a
questi dati lo facciamo bene siamo
sicuri ho fatto due esempi da
condividere con voi
ho cercato la parola donna semplice
potete farlo anche voi tranquillamente
cerco la parola donna è la prima
risposta che google mida sono soltanto
donne bianche la mia conoscenza
personale mi dice c'è qualcosa che non
va
siamo quasi 8 miliardi mancano tutte le
donne di colore le donne asiatiche le
donne con disabilità tutte bianche
quindi geo questo primo esempio che
potete fare tranquillamente sui vostri
cellulari fa pensare che la risposta che
google ci sta dando a qualche byas
secondo esempio parola amministratore
delegato io sono un amministratore
delegato e quando vado a cercare tro
cerco donne cerco persone di ambo i
sessi tutti maschi tutti bianchi la mia
conoscenza personale mi dice aldo la c'e
qualcosa che non va ma quante volte
quando noi cerchiamo non abbiamo questa
consapevolezza di sapere cosa
stiamo cercando e c'è un'asimmetria
informativa fra noi e questi giganti che
fa sì che quasi siamo obbligati a
crederci in quello che ci dicono ad
esempio che abbiamo visto di google è
ben noto google è già stata accusata del
fatto che il suo algoritmo è se si sta
perché di fatto con la parola alla
ricerca della parola si fa vedere
soltanto la 11 per cento di figure
femminili contro un 36 per cento che è
il dato reale
l'esempio di amazon è ancora più
preoccupante
amazon ha fatto un algoritmo per se
stesso e per cercare i curricola delle
persone competenti cercava delle figure
professionali haiti competenti e
l'algoritmo che aveva dei baia stessi di
fatto ha scartato i curricula delle
donne se questi giganti che sanno che
noi li osserviamo si permettono di avere
quei buyers immaginiamoci cosa c'è
negli altri nelle altre risposte che
riceviamo ma perché così dobbiamo capire
come funziona l'intelligenza artificiale
mentre nel algoritmi tradizionali è
l'uomo che inserisce le regole dentro
l'algoritmo quindi gli dice se vedi
questo input dammi questo output nel
caso dell'intelligenza artificiale si
dice che l'algoritmo impara apprende in
base ai dati che vede quindi se io gli
dò tutti dati con de bahia se dentro
oppure li do dei dati parziali non
neutri e chiaro che questo algoritmo mi
replica semplicemente quello che gli ho
insegnato
chi è che oggi scrive il codice
sorpresona
l'informatica e ma nei maschi soltanto
il 14 per cento delle donne in italia
sono nel mondo dell'informatica e di
questi 14 per cento pochissime oggi
stanno lavorando sull'intelligenza
artificiale però studio ormai ci dicono
che la tecnologia non è neutra che il
software scritto da un maschio è
differente dal soffre scritto da una
donna quindi è chiaro che noi ci
portiamo dentro a questi nuovi sistemi
buyers pregiudizi stereotipi che
influenzeranno la nostra vita al
problema degli addetti ai lavori comiche
miei amici mi è un nostro problema
perché questi sistemi di fatto
decideranno tutto decideranno se le
nostre ragazze potranno avere un domani
un mutuo
supponiamo che nell'albo ritmo chan baia
sessista per cui decide che le donne non
sono sposate sotto i 30
niente mutuo l'algoritmo e decideranno
il comportamento dei robot badanti che
si preoccuperanno di noi e felice ha un
buy ha spesso baia ce lo portiamo dietro
supponiamo che un drone militare deve
andare a sparare a un bersaglio e
s'accorge che lo vede c'è la telecamera
che nel bersaglio non c'è niente di
militare ma sono soltanto donne e
bambini cosa fa spara lo stesso è la
cosa che più di tutto mi sta a cuore
proprio per il lavoro che faccio la
creazione di farmaci e cure ad persona
da farmaci la medicina sta andando verso
quella che viene chiamato la evidence
space medici quindi tutto sarà basato
molto sui dati
ma se i dati che noi raccogliamo e diamo
questi algoritmi hanno dei buyers di
genere questi algoritmi per le donne non
funzioneranno abbiamo già detto con le
mie colleghe spesso siamo sole spesso
siamo soli in questi tavoli però bisogna
esserci
bisogna esserci in quantità quindi mai
più donne sole ma soprattutto bisogna
far sì che le donne possano decidere
quali intelligenza artificiale quale
conoscenza quali algoritmi andiamo a
mettere in questi sistemi
sono partita con una provocazione ci
possiamo fidare
io amo le intelligenze artificiali io mi
sono laureata intelligenza artificiale
25 anni fa i primi lavori che noi
facevamo aiutavamo i neurologi ad
esempio a fare le diagnosi la
segmentazione delle immagini la
segmentazione del genoma
io amo l'intelligenza artificiale ma ma
anche al contributo femminile
assolutamente e soprattutto
l'intelligenza artificiale talmente
potente che come aver scoperto di nuovo
una la bomba atomica dobbiamo regolarla
dobbiamo dargli delle regole dei buyers
positivi delle barriere perché un'arma
potentissima è talmente potente che vi
racconto chi con l'episodio personale
qualche anno fa con un gruppo di donne
abbiamo iniziato a lavorare sulla
segmentazione delle immagini di
risonanza magnetica al seno l'obiettivo
era quello di riconoscere delle lesioni
dei tumori alle diciamo a queste
immagini quando l'occhio umano ancora
non li vedeva una bellissima
collaborazione capitanata dalla mia
professoressa per questa salita c'è
stata una pioniera veramente in questo
settore è un giorno l'algoritmo nostro
riconosce purtroppo una macchia il
lericino lo vedevano quindi clinici mi
dicono ma noi non lo vediamo però
l'algoritmo dice che forse c'è una
lesione cosa facciamo e hanno deciso di
fare la biopsia e non ci date la mia
preoccupazione a dire sottopongo una
donna una biopsia magari è semplicemente
un falso positivo
purtroppo era un tumore ma molto
brevemente l'algoritmo non solo gli ha
salvato la vita ma c'è una novità
finalmente il world economic forum ci
dice che l'intelligenza emotiva è uno
skill tangibile concreto che i futuri
manager dovranno avere finalmente si
riconosce che le competenze tipiche
nostre femminili
la capacità di avere questa flessibilità
cognitiva questa empatia questa
intelligenza emotiva è uno skill
tangibile concreto ma se questo è e se
noi iniziassimo davvero e vedo tante
ragazze giovani in aule v vi esorto il
nostro contributo la nostra conoscenza
delle nostre competenze devono essere a
favore dell'umanità ci dobbiamo mettere
dentro
non possiamo più delegare ma perché c'è
questo byas perché soltanto il 14 per
cento delle donne delle ragazze italiane
decidono di affrontare materie
scientifiche perché il byas lo creiamo
noi siamo noi che a casa diciamo le
nostre figlie è la tecnologia una roba
da maschi
i maschi sono più portati ho assunto una
marea di ragazzi che programmano che
fanno le analisi sono bravissime quindi
questi byas questi stereotipi basta
le ragazze che io ho assunto sono brave
quanto forse a volte di più dei ragazzi
che ho assunto quindi assolutamente la
tecnologia non è una roba da uomini è
una cosa creativa che ha programmato sa
la bellezza di programmare e la
tecnologia crea offre un buon posto di
lavoro o un digital bees ma ci sono in
questo momento 240 mila posti di lavoro
che aspettano persone e quando c'è
questa disoccupazione giovanile vedere
che i giovani non trovano lavoro invece
questi lavori ci sono fa veramente
dispiacere e dov'è che nasce il vero by
us a casa quando i ragazzi vedono che
c'è un educazione differente fra maschi
e femmine
quando i ragazzi si accorgono che il
papa magari dice al maschio wifi
carriera la ragazza nota a casa
tranquilla cercato il posto fisso
e allora è lì che io veramente chiede ma
al papa il vostro lavoro è fondamentale
nella creazione della self confidence
delle vostre figlie è fondamentale dare
mpower mentale ragazze mio papà ma
sempre detto tu sei un campione tu vali
tue potenzialità e questa cosa mi ha
regalato una tale gioia
tale consapevolezza che gli sarò sempre
grato ma allora cosa possiamo fare se
davvero noi donne smettessimo di
delegare se fossimo lì presenti con i
nostri cervelli con le nostre competenze
a dare una mano ma l'intelligenza
artificiale a marta potentissima
possiamo davvero abbattere le malattie
possiamo davvero può creare dei robot
intelligenti empatici possiamo davvero
abbattere una marea di problemi che noi
abbiamo perché questi sistemi possono a
darci una mano
un concetto a cui sono particolarmente
affezionata la sorellanza digitale
noi in italia siamo fortunati perché
comunque viviamo con tutti i nostri
problemi
in un paese libero democratico quindi se
le ragazze non vanno a studiare non
fanno quelle materia una scelta
culturale che noi quasi lim poniamo ma
avrebbero le libertà invece ci sono
degli stati e lo sappiamo bene dove sono
e ragazze se volessero studiare e allo
stato che le impedisce di studiare è lo
stato che le impedisce di decidere con
chi sposarsi come vestirsi ma allora se
queste competenze non li offrissimo
anche a queste nostre sorelle in un modo
digitale piattaforme di telemedicina di
tele supporto immaginate che bellezza
quanto supporto noi potremmo dare a
tutte le ragazze più giovani del mondo
in tutto questo lavoro che ho fatto in
tutti questi anni di affiancamento di
mentore in di stare con le persone ho
capito l'importanza di quelle che io
chiamo alle mie tre c la competenza le
persone istruite trovano lavoro le
persone istruite sono utili quindi
fondamentale studiare continuare a
studiare all'infinito e crearsi questa
competenza ma ciò che forse manca le
nostre ragazze in italia soprattutto il
coraggio si diceva prima inventiamoci
una storia nuova e proprio così
smettiamo di dire alle nostre ragazze
fai la brava no vai spacca al mondo
smettiamo di libiche
smettiamo davvero di in divide tutte le
loro capacità al volo lo abbiamo parlato
siamo noi siamo noi genitori che
continuiamo a creare delle barriere a
queste ragazze
quindi appello alle giovani non sta
ascoltate troppo i vostri genitori
come dire diamo linfa vitale alle nostre
ambizioni alle nostre passioni perché
poi questo regala felicità regala gioia
e arriviamo alla nostra terza c il cuore
si vede lontano un miglio quando una
persona fa una cosa ci mette il cuore ci
mette la passione e quando una persona
lo fa un po così e allora spesso noi in
italia soprattutto le donne vedono
lavoro come un po una noia un melo
riconoscimento economico ma il lavoro e
passione il lavoro è dignità sociale un
ruolo sociale il lavoro da veramente
l'identità di una persona e quando una
persona fa un lavoro col cuore fa un
lavoro straordinario e quando le donne
decidono di mettere il loro cuore non
sono nella loro famiglia ma anche nel
loro lavoro e di che veramente nasce il
capolavoro la creazione
io penso che ci dobbiamo essere io penso
che se davvero ci mettiamo le nostre
competenze nostro cuore il nostro
coraggio se davvero iniettiamo
l'intelligenza emotiva di cui noi donne
siamo ricchissime nell'intelligenza
artificiale
allora ci possiamo fidare grazie
[Applauso]